[Applaudissements]
les amis mes amis
quelle campagne
[Applaudissements]
c'est donner tout ce que j'avais
l'équipe solidaire en donner tout ce
qu'elle avait je suis fier de nous
[Applaudissements]
je suis fier de la campagne qu'on a
menée campagne une campagne de vision je
suis fière de l'équipe qu'on a présenté
au Québec au Québécois
[Applaudissements]
on le savait on le savait en entrant
dans cette campagne là que ce serait pas
facile que ce soit il faut ensemble et
vrais affaires qu'on le veuille ou non
on est face à une vague cactus dedans
sur le contexte là si la tendance se
maintient Québec solidaire sera le seul
parti d'opposition à résister à cette
bataille
ce soir malgré tout ce soir malgré tout
Québec solidaire résiste à cette vague
et pour ça je vous dis merci
bien sûr je vous remercie je vous
remercie les Québécois et les
québécoises qui ont voté aujourd'hui
merci à vous qui avez fait confiance
avec solidaire pour la première ou pour
la cinquième fois cette confiance là je
vous promets on va tout faire pour la
vérité on ne vous laissera pas tomber
je vous dis merci bien sûr je veux dire
merci également au militants aux
militants de Québec solidaire merci
d'avoir porté notre mouvement sur vos
épaules pendant un mois merci à vous
merci
est-ce que les gens de la petite
batterie ce soir dans la salle
[Applaudissements]
merci merci
aux gens de Gwen de m'avoir accordé leur
confiance
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais et je dois beaucoup de choses à
bien du monde mais jamais plus qu'à une
personne qui me regarde en ce moment sur
le côté de la scène merci Maëlle merci
d'avoir fait ça à mes côtés merci
d'avoir été là merci de t'avoir de
t'être occupé de la petite comme ça
pendant un mois merci mon amour
[Applaudissements]
un peu plus tôt ce soir un peu plus tôt
ce soir j'ai une conversation avec
François Legault le premier ministre du
Québec je l'ai félicité pour sa
réélection et demain on va siéger
ensemble lui moi 123 autres députés à
l'Assemblée nationale du Québec dans un
nouveau Parlement du Québec et je veux
dire que Québec solidaire va être une
opposition vigilante on va être une
opposition de proposition on va proposer
des solutions et on va s'opposer à
toutes les mauvaises décisions
je veux je veux m'adresser à François
Legault bien sûr pour le féliciter de sa
réélection je veux le féliciter
publiquement mais je veux aussi lui dire
quelques mots sur le climat la lutte au
changement climatique ne peut pas
attendre 4 ans
c'est dans le prochain mandat que ça
passe ou ça Corse
[Applaudissements]
monsieur Legault monsieur Legault comme
chef de la CAQ vous avez attaqué sans
relâche les ambitions environnementales
de Québec solidaire on était en campagne
c'était de bonne guerre mais comme
premier ministre vous avez maintenant la
responsabilité d'être à la hauteur
monsieur Lego je ne vous demande qu'une
seule chose pour commencer ce deuxième
mandat écoutez la jeunesse du Québec
parce que parce que quelle que soit nos
résultats respectifs ce soir nous avons
tous la responsabilité d'écouter la
génération qui va devoir vivre avec les
conséquences de nos choix aujourd'hui il
n'est pas trop tard pour agir il n'est
pas trop tard pour changer d'idées il
n'est pas trop tard pour changer de cap
au Québec
je veux être clair je veux être clair
avec François Legault à chaque fois qui
va faire un pas en avant pour
l'environnement je serai son partenaire
à chaque fois qu'il va vouloir faire un
pas en arrière je serai son adversaire
[Applaudissements]
je veux prendre bien sûr au moment
également pour saluer madame anglaise
monsieur Saint-Pierre flamandon monsieur
duvet mon a de la chance au Québec
d'avoir une diversité d'idées et même
quand ça joue dur on a la chance de
pouvoir en débattre librement et en
général dans la sécurité ouais une
campagne électorale c'est exigeant c'est
exigeant pour tout le monde et ce soir
je pense pas seulement à ce qui me
sépare de mes adversaires je pense aussi
aux facteurs humains je pense au
soulagement qu'on va tous ressentir en
étant capable dans les prochaines
semaines de retrouver notre famille je
veux féliciter tout le monde pour la
campagne qu'il est elles ont mené
mes amis ce soir ce soir malgré tout
malgré tout on a des raisons de célébrer
ce soir la famille solidaire s'agrandit
ce soir les gens donnent c'est qu'on
voté pour le changement ce soir Maurice
Richard ville orange mes amis avant de
pouvoir à l'Assemblée nationale du
Québec
et ce soir et ce soir s'il a tendance se
maintient
vers d'un pourrait virer orange pour la
première fois et allez en grand
à l'Assemblée nationale du Québec
mes amis ce soir à Sherbrooke Christine
Labrie a gagné son pari
à Québec seuls
et les solidaires accueillent dans leur
famille Étienne grand monde entachereau
Manon Alexandre ruban Vincent ont gagné
leur Paris
bravo mais bien sûr je suis obligé
malheureusement de dire quelques mots
sur une femme que j'aime que j'admire
sur emilyse les sœurs terriens et mélise
mon ami merci merci d'avoir défendu pas
juste à circonscription merci d'avoir
défendu ta région ça a été un des grands
privilèges de ma vie de siéger avec toi
à l'Assemblée nationale du Québec les
gens de labitivité médicament ont eu une
défenseur une porte-parole absolument
extraordinaire dans les quatre dernières
années et je sais que tu vas continuer
de battre de battre avec un autre merci
pour tous Élise merci mille fois
[Applaudissements]
qu'est-ce qu'on s'en va faire à
l'Assemblée nationale
à partir de dans quelques semaines mais
on va se battre pour ce qui compte
vraiment on va se battre pour la santé
du monde pour la santé de
l'environnement on va se battre pour
régler la crise du logement pour des
loyer abordable pour des maisons
achetables on va se battre pour des
places en garderie des enseignantes dans
les classes on va se battre pour les
patients sur les listes d'attentes on va
se battre pour les soignants qui sont au
bout du rouleau on va se battre pour que
la solidarité revienne au coeur des
valeurs québécoises parce que la
solidarité entre les gens entre les
régions entre les peuples la solidarité
entre ma génération et la génération des
bâtisseurs c'est ça pour nous les
valeurs du Québec
mes amis cette élection-là en terminant
je suis obligé de vous parler de ça
cette élection là aurait dû être la
première élection au Québec où chaque
vote aurait compté
mais il y a des politiciens il y a un
politicien qui fait un calcul et qui a
rompu la promesse qu'il avait fait au
Québécois au Québécois
notre système politique est brisé notre
démocratie est malade et la carte
électorale ce soir ne reflète pas la
volonté politique des Québécois des
Québécoises il faut le dire il faut le
dire
il faut relancer la réforme du mode de
scrutin il faut que François Legault
reconnaisse le problème et il faut qu'il
travaille avec nous et avec tous les
autres partis pour qu'on règle ce
problème démocratique au Québec
le Québec
mes amis le Québec ce n'est pas
seulement la carte le Québec que je
connais le Québec que j'aime c'est un
Québec tu ouvres les bras le pays qu'on
veut construire il appartient aux hommes
et aux femmes qui veulent bien le
construire peu importe d'où ils viennent
parce que le plus important c'est où on
s'en va ensemble
mes amis la route de Québec solidaire
n'est pas terminée la route se relong
mais je suis confiant parce que changer
d'air au fond c'est quoi c'est bâtir un
avenir qui donne espoir moi j'ai espoir
je vous demande d'avoir espoir l'avenir
est en marche au Québec et vous en êtes
la preuve merci tout le monde merci pour
cette belle campagne ça a été un
privilège de vous représenter de parler
au nom de notre mouvement merci pour
tout
[Applaudissements]